[Music]
good afternoon my Sasha as you know
parole and a privilege it's a mistake
but it happened and if I were to be
released I would um I would just want
the simple life I just want to hold down
a job make some friends you know pay my
bills even if this was possible it made
20 people seven people why do you need
to do this cuz that's what I'm gonna how
long would it take you to make seven
pieces of jewelry in five or six hours
how long if I told you didn't have to
look at your mother anymore
it's need the water flask with your name
which man named wall which real name
8-ball what if we could make all this go
away in pairs as well sorry okay I'm
with my family I told him having a
garage let me tell you how big a job no
I'm out I take the job I'll be back
before you know can I come with you this
is mommy's very special work trip
[Music]
in three and a half weeks the Met will
be hosting its annual ball we are going
to Robin not the ball itself the neck of
Daphne Kluger valued at over a hundred
million dollars revenge it's a twofer do
not want a job in a job
[Music]
user Smith can't we just go to this do
we have to steal stuff yes
[Music]
is it your night acre the whole family
like this
literally
[Music]
[Music]